die freiheit ich zeige ihnen einmal die
seite eins der bild zeitung heute ist
verschoben grund es gibt krach in der
ampel eigentlich wollten wir am 20 märz
alle feiern unserem freedom day den
freiheitstag also endlich schluss mit
den corona maßnahmen doch ja einige
bundesländer trauen sich nicht die
kneifen ihre ausrede noch immer ist die
final darüber entschieden wie das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz aussehen soll
abgestimmt wird erst am freitag also
wenn sie in hamburg
mecklenburg-vorpommern brandenburg
rheinland pfalz wohne ich kann nur sagen
dann freuen sie sich nicht zu früh tja
zu früh sowieso nicht aber jetzt halt
noch später als spät darüber sprechen
wir mit unserem bild reporter julius
begrüße die julius freiheit verschoben
es wird nicht es bleibt uns ewig
erhalten offenbar so ist gerade das
gefühl zumindest bei mir diese corona
regeln
ja die angesprochenen länder versuchen
sich für die übergangsphase zwischen dem
jetzigen infektionsschutzgesetz und dem
was beim bundestag beschlossen werden
soll ein park oder maßnahmen festzulegen
weil sie eben ein bisschen ja gesagt mal
weiche knie bekommen beim blick auf die
aktuelle dann wieder ansteigen
infektionszahlen aber ich kann alle
leute beruhigen die ja wie dem defekt
sind die sehr gerne am zwanzigsten
jahrestag gefeiert hätten am zweiten
april ist dann wirklich schluss weil am
zweiten april endet die übergangsphase
das neue infektionsschutzgesetz dass
diese woche beschlossen wird tritt dann
offiziell in kraft und dann legt der
bundestag fest was die höchstgrenze der
maßnahmen ist und stand jetzt ist dass
im normalfall die maske in bus und bahn
die maske im alten krankenhaus und dort
auch noch test und ich denke wenn man
alte und kranke menschen so schützen
kann wenn die allermeisten sagen das
geht für mich in ordnung du sagst am
zweiten april ist wirklich schluss da
muss ich aber gleichen ich bin nicht
mehr politikerin ein aber aber aber
einfügen denn es ist ja auch wieder die
situation julius das diesmal zwar nicht
schwellenwerte ziehen aber man zumindest
sich offen lässt dass wenn die situation
sich zuspitzt etwa den krankenhäusern
das dann natürlich wieder weitere
maßnahmen getroffen werden können oder
versteh ich das falsch und das soll der
punkt wo der ampel krach ins spiel kommt
du sprichst die hotspot reglos auf
regional auf regionaler ebene begrenzt
sollen härteren maßnahmen angewendet
werden dürfen zweig masken pflicht
überall gibt die konzepte in der sage
ich mal museen oder restaurants als eine
anwendung finden aber eben nur in
regionen wo lokal das gesundheitssystem
angespannt ist und zu überlasten droht
der gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
liegt dass er weitaus sagt er erwartet
der sehr viele regionen diese hotspots
werden könnten ganze bundesländer
könnten diese hotspots werden der
minister für justiz also der juristische
experte sagt in einer neuen beim blick
auf dieses gesetz lege ich das völlig
anders bei einer experten im haus sagen
ich muss sehr genau bestimmen welche
region nicht festlege und ich muss sogar
in dem moment wenn einer in einem
kleinen in einem landkreis das kann ich
aus sagt er wir können nicht mehr
sinnvoll ist überlastet muss ich bevor
ich die menschen einsteiger überprüfen
kann ich menschen verlegen gibt es in
der nähe kapazität nicht ausnutzen kann
also so legen die juristen im
justizministerium
das neue gesetz aus das ist diese ampel
zoff und da wird es auch darum gehen wer
sich am ende durchsetzt lauterbach oder
buschmann
am ende des tages glaube ich eher den
juristen weil die entscheiden oder
gerichte entscheiden am ende die gesetze
in realität umgesetzt werden also am
ende des tages befürchtet man fast so
julius ist bleibt dann doch alles
ähnlich so wie es jetzt ist so berichtet
es für uns natürlich weiter weiß das
ganz genau im auge behalten was dann
nächste woche passiert und ob überhaupt
jemand am 20 märz oder am zweiten april
oder eventuell vielleicht gar nicht
feiern kann danke dir für deine
einschätzungen und es ist einfach so
wahnsinnig leid hier freiheit schon
wieder verschoben wenn sich die ampel
auf einem datum geeinigt hat dann kann
man sicher sein dass dieses datum auf
jeden fall wenig später wieder verändert
wird